pour parler des livres d'histoire avec
un grand h pour nos enfants et vous
allez nous prouver que finalement toutes
les périodes sont accessibles de manière
ludique à tous les enfants les jeunes et
moins jeunes finalement avec quelques
coups de coeur et notamment un coup de
coeur pour un petit album dont le titre
nous parle immédiatement celui d'une
célèbre émission de france 3 despatie
fun oui l'album s'appelle l'histoire
c'est pas sorcier et ils sont édités par
la maison d'édition de coq d'or jeudi il
un parce qu'il y en a des dizaines et
des dizaines alors certains parlent et
bien de personnages célèbres comme je le
sais ça et d'autre deux périodes
historiques comme la seconde guerre
mondiale alors l'idée est très simple
vous le voyez il y à des doubles pages
thématiques avec des petits points
lexique des points sur la période
historique et il y a énormément
d'illustration ça peut être des photos
des dessins ou énormément et bien de
petites choses en couleurs voilà qu'on
qu'on devine des bulles ça rend la
lecture très agréable et c'est destiné
aux enfants d'âge élémentaire à partir
de 7 ans alors ça permet de réviser et
bien les notions au programme ou de
s'intéresser à n'importe quel sujet
puisque parmi les personnages célèbres
on peut trouver jeu césar napoléon
cléopâtre où nelson mandela vraiment
c'est un petit album super a glissé dans
son cartable pour partager avec les
copains avec ses enseignants ou à lire
tranquillement dans son canapé à la
maison ça nous on aime dit moins fiables
on ne fait pas que de travailler au
lycée de mouchards dans le jura vient
quand même que que ses élèves ils sont
près de 450 apprenant entre guillemets
puisse aussi s'extérioriser j'imagine
qu'à une bibliothèque mais il ya
forcément peut-être d'autres choses
d'autres dérivatif pour eux bien sûr il
ya surtout des projets des projets
éducatif il ya là on donne de
l'importance à la culture je vous
parlais d'histoire tout à l'heure les
cours d'histoire géo pris une dimension
particulière on introduit l'histoire du
compagnonnage la condition ouvrière
l'émancipation et on essaie de donner du
sens aux enseignements à travers ce
qu'on appelle des coûts interventions à
travers même la notion de chef-d'oeuvre
mais pour les plus jeunes où ils
apprennent à le travail manuel et et
l'importance dans tout ça dont la
symbolique compagnie tu fais une petite
parenthèse rapide avant de repartir dans
la bibliothèque avec tiphaine vous
parlez de chefs-d'oeuvre on l'a vu tout
à l'heure à l'image assez cette
charpente là le chef-d'oeuvre c'est en
fait l'oeuvre des compagnons qui leur
permettent de valider le compagnonnage
c'est ça j'ai fait c'est tout à fait ça
l'étudiant itinérant à partir du moment
où du glee démarre son tour de france il
fait partie d'une société de métiers une
société compas l'unique avec des anciens
qui vont lui apprendre qu'ils vont lui
transmettre bénévolement les métiers est
telle que votée qui doit être enseignée
et au bout d'un an ou deux il va
présenter un premier travail qui
s'appelle le premier chef-d'oeuvre pour
être pour être comment dirais-je pour
faire partie de cette société compas
compagnie pour être sociétaire comme on
dit chez nous
ce premier travail là c'est déjà le
travail manuel c'est déjà pour sublimer
ce que mes anciens - prix allez une
autre collection a retenu notre
attention c'est simple c'est pratique
c'est lui dit que c'est comme on aime
tiphaine ces questions réponses de nos
temps ça peut pas être plus clair la wii
alors c'est une question très
généraliste mais je crois pas qu'ils
aient fait d'album sur les compagnons je
voulais vous parler de celui ci un la
guerre d'algérie c'est l'un des derniers
albums qu'ils soient parus et c'est
vraiment très très intéressant parce que
le sujet était un peu épineux est donc
laissée de côté mais là il est traité de
manière très intelligente pour les
enfants dès 7 ans grâce à des dessins
vous le voyez et des photographies des
manuels cerisier mais aussi grâce aux
textes de jean michel billioud alors
aucun point n'est laissé de côté 1 qui
sont les colons qui sont les harkis qui
allaitaient le rôle du fln de l'eau as
et on parle même de la torture c'est
vraiment un livre très intéressant qui
intéressera à la fois les enfants mais
même les adultes ans parce que c'est
très simplement expliqué vous voyez les
illustrations sont magnifiques vraiment
je vous le conseille et ça s'appelle la
guerre d'algérie ces questions réponses
chez nathan sabah super ans et ce chez
nathan nathan qui cherchent de nouvelles
manières finalement d'aborder l'histoire
avec les enfants et qui a aussi lancé dd
romande histoire fiction avec des
enfants qui voyagent dans le temps pour
essayer de comprendre les problématiques
actuelles ça c'est un sacré job dit mme
thyssen et oui et alors pour y arriver
un évidement quoi de mieux que la
fiction ça s'appelle explorateurs de
l'histoire vous voyagez deux numéros ici
et c'est l'historienne laurence de cock
qui s'est lancé un défi
alors elle a créé un petit personnage
qui s'appelle eole et qui est un passeur
de temps ils emmènent des enfants dans
n'importe quelle période historique pour
leur permettre de comprendre et bien ce
qui se passe à l'heure actuelle alors
par exemple pourquoi est ce que des gens
déboulonne les statue de christophe
colomb alors que c'est un si grand
explorateur ou pourquoi a t'on inventé
l'école louis drôle d'idée on pourrait
se le demander et bien ces petits livres
sont assez drôles paraissent comme ça de
la fiction mais ils permettent de
réfléchir à des problématiques actuelles
il mêle un peu de philosophie avec de
l'histoire et ils permettent de
questionner cette vision que l'histoire
est immuable et profite toujours au
vainqueur vraiment c'est à mettre entre
les mains des enfants de 9 ans pour
développer l'esprit critique aller votre
dernier coup de coeur un coup de coeur
qui a obtenu le prix spécial du jury au
festival de la bande dessinée à
angoulême
un événement dire vous avez peut être
suivi sur les écrans connectés de france
tv c'est vraiment une plongée cette fois
ci au coeur de la résistance en est
toujours dans l'histoire avec un grand h
ça s'appelle des visions et vous le
voyez là on change de format on passe à
la bd xxl mais ça vaut vraiment le coup
c'est une bande dessinée magistral
publié par les éditions
2024 et sa relaxe l'engagement de la
filière de résistance du musée de
l'homme à paris et le parti pris des
auteurs est assez intéressant puisque
raphaël metz
louise moaty et simon aux uns sont
partis uniquement de documents réels ils
sont partis d'une somme de 800 mille
caractères l'équivalent d'un livre de
1000 pages ans pour écrire ce récit en
bande dessinée alors les lettres le
journal intime des résistants on peut
citer paul nivet boris vildé yvonne aux
dons et il raconte et bien les petits
gestes de résistance au quotidien les
craintes les trahisons c'est vraiment un
livre très très intéressant ça parle de
la philosophie universaliste de la
résistance aux idées d'extrême droite et
aux idées nazies c'est totalement
d'actualité c'est à mettre entre les
mains de tous les adolescents et tous
les adultes je vous le conseille ça
s'appelle des vivants un peu c'est super
sélection livra retrouverez aussi sur le
net et les réseaux sociaux avec tous vos
écrans connectés